on le sait avant d'être élu président de
l'ukraine volodymyr lnd qui a joué un
professeur d'histoire propulsé chef de
l'état de son pays dans une série
comique à succès aujourd'hui un extrait
daté de 2015 devient virale le
personnage reçoit un appel d'un gué la
merkel vue annonçant que l'ukraine est
acceptée dans l'union européenne
c'est exactement ce que demandent les
dden free dans la vraie vie pour se
défendre contre la russie vous rappelez
de comment on était quand le monde
entier était en pause pendant le coc
vide de comment on était quand les il
était calme
2 comment on était quand on a vu des
canards dans paris
on a vu des canards se rendre à la
comédie française
malheureusement les représentations sont
annulées et personne ne les avait prévu
[Musique]
un passage prophétique mais dans la
fiction c'est la joie est de courte
durée
et derrière
haro sur le toit
et c'était le dernier jt d'arreter
france après donc cette décision de
l'union européenne de nos bannir de
l'espace européen jusqu'au bout nous
avons travailler librement avec sérieux
honnêteté présentant tous les points de
vue respectant toutes les opinions
donnant la parole à ce qu'on entend
parler dans les médias traditionnels
pour vous donner une information
complète nous avons toujours respecté
les règles et qui s'imposait à nous nous
sommes aujourd'hui touchées par une
décision arbitraire sont contradictoires
possible la communauté internationale
condamne à une très large majorité de
pays l'invasion russe en ukraine lors
d'un vote à l'assemblée générale des
nations unies une résolution réclamant
le retrait immédiat des troupes du
kremlin a été adopté par 141 pays trente
cinq se sont abstenus et cinq ont voté
contre la russie la biélorussie la corée
du nord l'erythrée et la syrie une
décision qui crée un précédent dangereux
pour la liberté de la presse la liberté
d'expression de devrions tous là
regretté profondément rt ce ne sont pas
que des journalistes se sont aussi des
personnels administratifs investi des
techniciens des maquilleuses de talent
merci à vous chers équipe merci à xénia
fait de revin pour sa confiance totale
et merci à vous tous pour votre fidélité
et votre soutien ouattara qu'est ce que
vous faites à am soc trang front puis je
suis prêt à prendre cette personne dans
ma voiture des mamans des enfants qui
voudraient aller vers l'ouest
pourquoi vous êtes là aider c'est pas le
moment de rester sur son canapé quand
même on a envie d'être ensemble trouver
c'est un peu dur en ce moment donc on va
on va aussi vous proposer un peu de
divertissement savage ouanna très bien
on essaie de se dire bah qui font parler
et puis qu'il faut aussi penser un petit
peu honteuse on vient de l'apprendre la
mort de jean pierre pernaut l'ancien
présentateur du jt de tf1 à 13h est mort
à l'hôpital à l'âge de 71 ans il avait
annoncé il ya quelques semaines qui
souffre à nouveau d'un cancer cette fois
ci d'un cancer des poumons trois ans
seulement après avoir vaincu un cancer
de la prostate c'est sa famille qui a
annoncé sa mort il ya quelques minutes
on vient d'apprendre une terrible
nouvelle je suis bouleversée
enfin rendre hommage jean pierre pernaut
nous a quittés et bien de vous quitter
je suis désolé bon jean pierre pernaut
avait présenté le 13 heures de tf1
pendant 32 ans personne n'avait misé en
valeur les régions aussi bien que lui
tout comme le terroir et l'artisanat
français qu'il affectionnait tant le
président de la république emmanuel
macron qui prend la parole ce soir et il
entendu on pourra le suivre sur bfm tv
viennent publié un tweet jean pierre
pernaut a habité le coeur de nos foyers
durant trente ans il a donné rendez vous
à 13h aux françaises et aux français
pour leur transmettre les dernières
informations mais aussi sa passion de la
france de nos régions de notre
patrimoine nous ne l'oublierons pas le
premier ministre jean castex la france
des territoires perd cette voix
familière et ce visage rassurant qui
parlait si bien adèle et savait si bien
lui parlait pas un mot de notre pays ne
lui était inconnu pas une tradition de
nos terroirs ne lui était étranger ça ça
j'avoue que je crois que aucun d'entre
nous si on a suivi le trésor ne peut
ignorer les santons les sabots les
guirlandes les le mec était partout tout
le temps il avait interviewé les quatre
chefs quatre chefs d'état de de
mitterrand à maquereau il ya congestion
qui avait refusé
les a tous fait
hollande il a occupé il va toujours y
voyez il fallait que des émissions de
bobo hollande c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
oublié un jeu vous dire ainsi hollande
faisait des bonnes ses missions le sol
lors de la prochaine émission qui fera
je pense que ce sera top chef trop de
trous trous ni de troupes trop de trop
tu le trouve
trop de trop tu le trot je vais m'y
rendrai juste vous la de ce côté-là
et ainsi ça s'enlève un fait ça c'est
plus bravo sherlock une fois épluché
vous est mince et votre échalotes
comment ça se passe
mais je sais pas comment ça se niche
alors je suis perdu je vais viser
cette vidéo il y a deux camps d'un côté
ceux qui aiment ce genre d'éducation
trouve la petite mignonne à essayer de
se servir seul et de l'autre ceux qui
manqueraient de patience ou fustige le
gaspillage alimentaire avec plus de 10
millions de vu la séquence a ouvert un
débat sur l'éducation des enfants mais
le but des parents derrière son compte
instagram semble tout autre sphère
débuts avec la maladresse de leur fils
et on salue tous les codes rare qu'ils
sont nombreux si tu allais quand même
pas là pour subir tous ses malheurs si
une chasse il s'est mis avec greg c'est
parce qu'il est rigolo ce parce qu'il
est drôle parce qu'il est beau parce
qu'il est fun un moment donné le mec qui
lui montre que la mauvaise passe est il
peut pas penser qu'à lui le point c'est
que greg il est trop nombriliste faut
clairement qu'ils mettent de l'eau dans
son vin
et en sautant de la main
ah ouais je les bâtards
tranquille ou quoi alors c'est qui
ferait du tort de scam pierrot 64 pages
qui crèche à alençon et qui kiffent plus
rac et c'est bon aussi edf je sais pas
ce que ça veut dire
comment ces trompes abusé comment il
n'aura manqué c'est sale bâtard
[Rires]
et oui monsieur le ministre les petites
boules que vous avez vu ce sont celles
de jacques lob qui nous a gentiment
autorisés à tourner dans les jardins du
palais royal il est pas boules de jack
lang les deux boules de la chanson à
présent
[Musique]
bonne fête cordonnier et la ford fiesta
à toi tu es mal fichu
[Applaudissements]